it ended like this in a field in
america's midwest the fugitive's car
showing the damage caused when
authorities deliberately crashed into it
to stop them and a 10-day hunt was over
casey white was serving 75 years and
facing the death penalty vicki white no
relation was a respected prison director
on the verge of retirement yet on april
the 29th she escorted him out of jail in
alabama she told colleagues she was
taking him for a mental health
evaluation but instead in a sheriff's
car fled
when police were tipped off about a man
resembling the six foot nine inch white
at a car wash the net was closing in the
pickup truck they'd been using was also
found abandoned
as they were about to be arrested vicki
white shot herself and later died in
hospital casey white is now back in
custody we got a dangerous man off the
street today
he is never going to see the lie today
again
and
you know that's a good thing for not
just our community but that's a good
thing for this country
vicki white's family said they were
stunned by her involvement but
authorities said it was clear this had
been planned for some time
her death means they may never fully
know the reasons why on what was meant
to be her last day at work she risked
everything for a man with such a
threatening and violent history greg
milam sky news los angeles